je peux pas j'ai eu l'idée du siècle
encore chaussure à son pied on emploie
des gens qui vont porter les chaussures
de nos clients tu connais des gens qu'on
papier
je compte sur toi fred anniversaire de
ta soeur est ce que quelqu'un mais bien
j'ai donc lu ce message vous ne savez un
peu compliqué pour vous en fait c'est
gelé pour et je devrais leur serrer la
nuit est ce que je pourrais avoir un
petit but avec mon petit peu d'argent
[Musique]
il a vu la vie qu'ils mènent leur donne
une leçon
oliphant salies
on n'a plus d'argent ils veulent nous
foute reprise pardon
soit caché à marseille un truc que vous
a jamais fait de votre vie on fait venir
travailler bon c'est pas venir comme
j'en ai pas de diplômes parce que je
suis quelqu'un d'autodidacte ces pays
combien ce livre de 100 euros c'est par
semaine c'est ça non par jour comme
francis cabrel il a appris la guitare
tout seul le mois ce business
et dans ce cas c'est peut-être quelque
chose pour vous mais il ya le véhicule
de fonction et je serai pas déçu
oui t'as jamais été là à vous avez
manqué de rien si tu parle d'argent non
c'est toute chose dont on avait dit un
peu pas
[Musique]
est-ce que je donnerais pour voir ça
enfin bon ça ça va les courbes
je pense qu'on va beaucoup apprendre de
cette expérience et
on espérait ce qui se passe je veux
c'est sûr que c'est vraiment porter goss
que tu fais ça
maintenant faut dormir que
jesse n'aurait pas vu les clés
n'a pu cependant la main
reste là
là je venais
bienvenue au paradis on est où là
tu me traîner avec nous qui doit passer
ni preuves avant le seul truc que tu as
à faire c'est aller à l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
c'est ici chez toi maintenant est-ce que
c'est clair
tu deviendras grand effort comme lui
il y en a certains qui doivent laisser
le mal sorti il n'y a que la souffrance
qui peut l'évacuer la lumière s'est
coiffé pas les éclairages de noël donc
il vous prévient avant de venir vous
torturer sauf que c'est pas lui qui nous
torture
[Musique]
moi je sortirai d'ici
dont il on prendra nos familles on peut
c'est super tout juste consomme à la
lave et il ne repose que sur des choix
sais tu n'as pas le choix
alors tu n'as rien
monsieur le président on peut
légitimement s'interroger sur la
situation critique que traverse la
société française le pensez-vous pas y
être sourd pour un puissant j'ai
beaucoup de défauts et on peut toujours
faire mieux mais je ne prends pas avoir
été saoul
c'est une attaque de drone
et civils des enfants des hommes et
femmes du nord super
[Musique]
c'est incroyable comme les gens thème
est la plus grands journalistes de
france france pourquoi ce besoin de
devant mettre en scène que le gars qui
élabore la solaire et brandissent on a
l'impression d'avoir une mission génial
calanques elle à cette fille vous avez
tous été formidables formidable c'était
formidable de pas mourir vous les
journalistes vous courez après l'audimat
sap et donc aux leçons de morale vous
les gardez pour vous les vôtres et vous
idiot et ça va aller mappus aura un
effet dire pour choisir les bijoux et
l'arabe
je ne supporte plus le regard des gens
les gens vont te détester puis tu adores
et c'est la même chose
c'est par tokyo marie c'est pas ton
argent c'est notre argent je gagne 5
fois plus que toi ça explose
c'est génial
[Musique]
théâtre
ça la matière des icônes
elles ont fait de deux bouts jean
crevettes ce métier tu sais elle pleure
la france maintenant
cette célébrité s'ils démentent
c'est la télé pour moi c'est comme ça
que ça marche
le pire c'est le mieux
il était une fois une princesse pas
comme les autres
moi s'est-il
ses griffes et elle est touffu et voilà
d'une tonne
bienvenue dans ma ville rende rhume
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les baiseurs céline dounia la rue
alors on doit se débrouiller tout c'est
au le voilà j'ai thoiry
un beau jour il a fallu que je me
déguise tours et châtellerault garde
depuis tout le monde me propose
d'acheter salut on dirait que je n'aime
que pris la gauche a
mis le cruel régentry star à un point
donné notre prince
il a transformé aux reproches à poules
mouillées chameau tupou qu'est
ce que c'est
[Musique]
il me faudra du courage
et surtout n'allez pas dans l'ombre
attendez il va y avoir des trucs
dangereux
massa possible long feu du ballon petit
choc
pado
je suis la seule à pouvoir sauver le
royaume
personne ne peut s'opposer à moi
blake c'est eux qu'on a dans le coeur
fils
on est en sécurité ici
ah bah non le 11 août au cinéma
ok les enfants les équations du second
degré
dans ses cauchemars
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis calme
c'est
oui
non
[Musique]
sur la tête de la première section de la
2e compagnie
situation familiale j'ai un enfant de 7
ans et épouse est avocat
[Musique]
un choix que j'ai fait ensemble et je
suis né conséquence
des questions des soucis les angoisses
paraissent
maintenant
je pense que ça va très très bien se
passer
orange par pour la passer
c'est dans on ne voulait pas passons
oh
[Musique]
ce jour de la
fin pourquoi tes talents
[Musique]
on vous demande pas d'avoir envie de
téléphoner pour ceux qui ont une femme
qui attend c'est un ordre
[Musique]
laplaud connect de tout
quand même je suis très amoureuse de
moitié ses propres terres
c'est vrai que c'était pas ma vie d'être
mariés en juin
c'est par concerne
[Musique]
je suis surexcitée
je savoir
puis je veux pas savoir alors nous y
voilà
j'aime
bien sûr je sais quelques petites choses
à force de lire des livres mais je suis
censé croire que cet anglais n'existe
pas pourquoi ça ne suffit pas pour que
ton mari ne suffit-il pas vous couchez
encore ensemble j'aurais parié tu me
poserait cette question j'aime savoir ce
qui se passe dans ta tête mais j'ai pas
l'intention d'y répondre
à supposer que je meure écrin biographe
tombe sur ton nom qu'est ce que tu veux
dire est il n'a pas écrit un seul de ses
livres ils ont été écrits par toute une
série de maîtresses et moi j'ai écrit
les deux derniers émois 6 à l'humilier
c'est un jeu
il est où mon livre quel est le livre
dans lequel je suis et je suis venu un
temps dentelle et tu as voulu que je
monte dans ta chambre
et la petite américaine il faut lui ses
quais en fait je sais bien que très
vaguement du tout ah bah désolé
naturel mort tu m'as manqué qu'est ce
qui te manquer je veux savoir non pas de
propos grivois s'il te plait je suis un
écouteur je suis un audiophile le duo
filmé mais quelle connerie prétentieuse
très antique
[Musique]
ll n'est que des mots j'ai beau essayer
je suis pas capable de baisers des mots
je me fous de ce que les gens
comprennent ou ne comprennent pas au
congrès une première
[Musique]
ainsi donc qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
quand tu veux te demander d'où vient ce
bleu sur la cuisse il a déjà fait bon et
alors bah j'ai dit la vérité j'ai
toujours la vérité comme ça on ne se
laisse pas piéger par le change
[Musique]